uh Midnight Club yes Mike Flanagan
created wrote If you don't know him
Haunting of Hill House Oculus uh hush it
goes on and on he's amazing he's a kind
soul he's super talented
um Dr sleep what was it like working
with Mike Lanigan
did you have any of those big monologues
no oh my God yeah some people have that
yes were they scared yes he has those
and that's one of the reasons why I
don't I'm too scared to work with him
right now I don't I can't learn a
three-page monologue yeah that's
terrifying yeah I won't get through it
not three pages I'll go I'll get through
a half page and then we'll you know then
I'll just I'll go okay what's the line
and then you'll have about three
cutaways that's it but what was he like
um Mike video
no so it's very Mike is like you said he
is just the most warm kind he is he's
just such a grounded individual and he
like it just Bloom it made me enjoy the
experience and enjoy working with him
even more just seeing what a great
person he is but I think something I
love is just how clear his vision is and
how that shines through in the way that
he directs us as acting he knows what he
wants he knows what he wants and that
was really great working with somebody
like that who would just come up and be
like hey Larson try it like this and
then I'd be like oh you're right I
didn't even like think of doing it like
that let's do it let's just try it and I
love like the so for the Midnight Club
most of the um within the group of kids
it was some of them their first project
and so I remember we did like a uh at
our table read the first and during like
prep the first two weeks Mike took us
through and just basically like
showed us walked through basically
everything you'll need to know to be an
actor on set and if anybody get fired
from the table read no okay keep going
yeah
and I'll just
really in
and I think it was like very helpful
that what I love about him too is the
fact that he gives people a chance you
know what I mean Mike isn't he wants to
see you shine yes and he's very just
welcoming and made it everyone feel so
comfortable like he's so experienced and
everyone was just like learning what to
do for the first time and he was like
Hey for the first take do what you've
practiced second take have you know have
some fun with it third take do whatever
you want let's just lose everything lose
everything you lose everything you've
set up in your mind and the choices
you've made and it was always like that
yeah like that's how it always should be
that's what I would say read it how it's
written first second if we got it then
we're gonna go ever just try something
yes um did you work with my good buddy
Robert Long Street no oh you think it's
working he played the janitor no I
haven't seen it yet I'm gonna watch it
yeah I haven't seen it yet do you do any
um accents by the way or uh Impressions
no you can't do any Impressions I mean
dialects I really need to work on my
British accent I'm like well I'm not
that's the one thing I'm I could do a
better Australian I think Hmm path
Adelaide Sydney great and my family's
all from Melbourne on my mom's side you
ever go there never been it's awesome oh
I want to go so bad it's awesome I've
been there a couple times Robert Long
Street uh he was the janitor at Midnight
Club for two episodes let me see he is
this you'll know him you'll go oh yeah
watch this dude oh yeah oh yes okay no
so I didn't meet him
sad was he good yes he's always good I
mean what I love about the Midnight Club
is it's very which I'm very sad it
didn't get picked up for a second season
but you know were you surprised yeah I
was a little bit surprised I think it's
that was too because everything Flanagan
does it goes yeah yeah and I I think
though the the message even within the
first season is just so well done and I
think it you know it explores life and
death Through The Eyes of young kids I
love the concept and it's just the way
that Christopher bike and actually
reading up the story behind how the
Midnight Club came to be for Christopher
[__] like a mother of um her daughter
who was very sick reached out to him
with cancer and said that they would
meet and like talk about Christopher
Christopher Pike's books at night so she
said can you write a book about us and
that's how the Midnight Club came to be
and I'm like wow that is just so
incredible and then the way that Mike
just you know through all the stories
how each you know story feeds into the
past of the characters or you know
feeds their own character development
was just so well done like I just am
blown away like being able to see the
whole thing because I didn't get to work
with the seven kids directly I'm playing
back in the 60s young Samantha slain so
I didn't get to act with them um as a
group so being able to watch the series
straight through and see them as a unit
and gosh my friend Ruth Cod she just
blew me away really and her backstory
she was found off Tick Tock and so talk
about like how things have changed it's
just like isn't that amazing back in the
day
if you did TV you couldn't do film hmm
and film people snobs I'm not doing TV
wow and now everybody wants to do TV yes
everybody wants to do a series stream
you name one person who doesn't Kevin
Costner's doing it everybody does it
yeah Helen mirren's doing a new like
series or some [__] that's so wild so it
was like Harrison Ford yeah so if it was
like if you're in TV you're gonna do
what you want now